the masasi is the place where they all
can have a shelter together with
International organizations we created
shelters for the Palestinian Oho she got
roasted by Sky the guy just clipped and
went yeah here's where she wants them to
go just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you remind us download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends this is an video we're going to
react to from CNN exposing the Israeli
Ambassador this vile individual who is
who said stuff like there's not a
humanitarian crisis in Gaza you she
saying she has no empathy for them
either 100% she's going we're going to
watch in this video just look at where
she's telling them to go as a safe haven
it must be a good place must be a happy
place is well this person she sees the
Palestinians as animals that's why let's
see what she has but did she say that
ear though she doesn't need to she's
demonstrated it yeah the defense guy
said it is it Human animals human
animals yes she has but this woman also
sees them she doesn't need to say it we
can't see it a video Let's watch it for
hour let's watch the video yeah my dear
brother he says I will not have another
brother like you you bury me with him
the dead wrapped in white the plac
together on the street the living pray
for them there are many constants in
Gaza now mourning is just one of them
those who can are following Israeli
orders to head further south they're
leaving by any means possible but quite
often on foot few believe anywhere is
safe but speaking to Sky News the
ambassador to the UK insisted that there
is at least one safe area Israel made
sure there is is a place for the people
of Gaza to have their shelters there is
there is there is a river there is a
place in Gaza called the masasi the
muasi is the place where they all can
have shelters uh together with
International organizations we created
shelters for the Palestinian people so
you cannot say Israel is not you know
facilitating that together with
humanitarian this is where she's talking
about a desolate Wasteland of sandunes
next to the Mediterranean Sea there is
no Aid in Al maazi there are no Aid
agency tents there are no food kitchens
there is no help here bro she got
roasted by Sky the guy just clipped and
went yeah here's where she wants them to
go this is desolate there's no there's
no place for eating there's no place for
this yeah thean Aid there's nothing
there's literally nothing but this just
shows you that these individuals if if
they were seeing the Palestinians as
human beings they would they would not
say say such thing you know what's very
ironic it's very crazy yeah what's crazy
it's the following the Israelis are so
confident in the themselves that they
coming up with these blunders of Monday
Tuesday Wednesday they under tunnel now
I want to show you an operational tunnel
the tunnel is built with electricity you
can see the tunnel the tunnel is L down
more than 20 M
down like it's crazy bro they're not
even trying it shows like nanah said yes
Satan yahu Satan Satan yahu okay yes
that's what his name is that's why he
said he said we control America so think
yes it's that's what's happening and
guess what that's why the far right
Americans are waking up and saying hold
on a second we put America first before
Israel why are we so fixated with Israel
now the point is this Ambassador this
individual who has no shame you can see
from her face she has no shame is
telling that the Palestinians should go
to this Barren desert this place where
there is no help and it basically saying
you're either going to die from the
bombs or you going to die starving M
that's what you're saying tell me tell
me if I'm wrong to be honest I agree
with you when in the first last week
we've had them being called Human
animals and we're seeing kids and
they're saying and they instead of
referring to them as kids as innocent
humans they call them miners they call
them collateral damage that's something
you hear that's an industrial term yes
collateral damage that's such a
heartless term object yeah you're
literally dehumanizing them and now
let's not get it twisted these news
organizations have been boycotted by
people their veneer has been peeled off
and now people are seeing them from the
propaganda tools that they are and
that's why they're now having to play
okay no but let's let's put a bit of
pressure on them but the blood is on
your hands the video that you've done of
the Brit who has traveled to Israel and
died become a martyr for
Israel he's become radicalized by new
stations like this yes exactly so you
know what this is what we need to teach
our kids this is is Clips like this that
we need to be sharing because and when
we're seeing that Clips are being shared
of the news being so imbalanced so
blatantly on the side of Israel ignoring
war crimes that are taking place bro
genocide experts are calling this a
textbook genocide literally textbook
genoci even Gary lilica ended up
retweeting that interview that Owen
Wilson Owen Jones did with that genocide
expert Allah I mean how clear and you
know what sometimes I on on certain
platforms I I speak to these people
Israeli soldiers most of them they're
not even Jewish they're actually
atheists of course on top of that these
people they say you know what obviously
we're going to Value Israeli life over
Palestinian life so if that's how you
see and even Speakers Corner when we're
meeting with them we're talking with
them this is Grassroots people and
that's the that's the issue that's why
how can we take what Israel and the
Israeli authorities are saying they're
saying no no don't take from Hamas
they're terrorists but you've got
Amnesty International Human Rights Watch
and all of these organizations that are
saying no the the terrorists are also
Israel as well because of the objective
International war crimes they've
committed exactly exactly and the thing
is in never in history of Islam you
would ever see Muslims ever when they're
conquering lands to treat to treat a
group of people like the way Israel is
never in theory history of Islam you
would see Muslims going and
indiscriminately massacring men women
and children it is against our religion
and we've said it before we are morally
consistent while the Western World and
Israel these occupiers are only
strategically consistent that's all we
have to say brother and sisters this
individual this V being has been exposed
once again shame on you and we will
carry an expose on you guys share this
video far and wide good job Al good job
it's it's teamw work come on it's teamw
work Makes the Dream Work yeah
together forever inshallah that includes
you guys carry on the boyot carry on the
post Mak in we will be
[Music]
victorious